bonjour à vous trois bonjour c'est une
image impressionnante je dois dire c'est
rare qu'on vous voit réunis les trois sa
première fois que vous faites un
exercice comme ça votre vue les trois
ensemble bravo Madame Roy on a beaucoup
parlé depuis des mois et des mois de
sentiments d'insécurité à Montréal
est-ce que on commence à apaiser où on
n'arrive pas à trouver la façon
d'apaiser un peu ce sentiment
d'insécurité
vous savez monsieur roi un citoyen qui
est insécure c'est un citoyen de 3 donc
le pour nous au service de police le
sentiment de d'insécurité est plus
important que la sécurité comme telle
parce que dès que j'ai un citoyen qui
est insécure il faut que je prenne les
actions pour le rassurer ce qui est le
cas actuellement parce que c'est
intéressant ce que vous dites entre les
statistiques pures parce que oui une
augmentation des actes avec armes à feu
à Montréal à Longueuil à Laval également
mais
l'impression c'est que c'est vraiment
beaucoup moins sécuritaire elle est
réelle cette impression cette impression
là elle est réelle parce que c'est une
c'est très personnel le sentiment de
sécurité ou d'insécurité donc oui c'est
tout à fait réel
même chose Monsieur
Daguerre à Longueuil c'est pas la même
proportion mais vous avez apaiser votre
population oui on l'apaisé
quand même 5 meurtres en un week-end
donc c'est ce que le sentiment de
sécurité la perception d'être en
insécurité et très palpable puis c'est à
ce moment-là faut absolument travailler
en amont sur comment rattraper le lien
de confiance avec la population nordière
et des actions qui sont posées et des
gestes qu'on fait concrètement mais
surtout les communiquer mais aussi
l'aspect la police peut communiquer
communiquer communiquer mais souvent ce
qu'on s'aperçoit ça prend une communauté
qui doit communiquer aussi ça prend des
partenaires les groupes communautaires
c'est un esprit de village qui doit
prendre ça de ce genre d'insécurité là
et pas juste la police je branchais à
Laval
aussi il y a eu des événements est-ce
que là vous êtes outillés
pour faire face à la nouvelle
criminalité est-ce que vous êtes bien
infiltré ce que vous avez une bonne
connaissance du milieu des jeunes
notamment ouais ben je vous dirais on a
lancé l'opération Center il y a
maintenant environ un an pour travailler
en équipe vraiment de façon très
structurée toute vraiment le
renseignement c'est de la guerre c'est
de la guerre en termes de renseignement
vous savez influencer aussi notre
connaissance du milieu ce que vous
parlez c'est les jeunes on est très
présent dans les écoles on fait des
activités de prévention aux activités
sportives il y a des policiers et là
c'est là que ça se passe ce qu'on veut
c'est éviter que le jeûne prenne des
plus vieux plus criminalisés plus
violents comme modèle puis décide de
suivre cette voie là c'est ce qu'on
essaie de tenter mais vous êtes on est
là mais on a l'impression quand même que
la les services de police sont quand
même dépassés par ces groupes de jeunes
qui font passer des armes de plus en
plus comme c'était des objets usuels
l'impression que vous êtes un peu
dépassé j'aurais pas ça je vous dirais
on a des beaux succès cette année on
perdu à 52% moins de décharge arme à feu
puis il y a des succès des autres
organisations puis si on a réduit à
Laval c'est entre autres l'excellent
travail des policiers de Montréal et de
Longueuil et de sauter du Québec je vous
dirais aussi ceux qu'on focus sur les
fusillades c'est des événements
malheureux c'est des drames à chaque
fois il reste qu'il y a beaucoup de
travail à travers colossa expert en
termes d'arrestation saisit dans ma feu
le travail d'équipe est vraiment bien
implanté parce qu'à Montréal on se
rappelle des deux meurtres Saint-Denis
centre commercial Raclin les gens se
disent j'aurais pu être là avec mon bébé
ça ce que depuis qu'est-ce que vous
faites très concrètement qu'est-ce qu'on
fait pour réagir à ça en fait évidemment
dans le défi on devient meilleur je
pense que ça c'est c'est important de
souligner mais on continue à travailler
d'arrache-pied au niveau des enquêtes
bien entendu et on le dit on le répétait
je pense qu'on fait front commun tous
les quarts de police on le dit on le
répète ça va prendre aussi de la part de
tout le milieu parce que un changement
de culture à l'intérieur présentement du
milieu criminel qui s'installe sur un
milieu criminel une culture ça se met
pas en prison donc il va falloir
travailler tout le monde ensemble
expliquez ça dans vos mots là qu'est-ce
qui se passe pourquoi il y a plus
d'événements et car ma feu qu'est-ce qui
se passe dans la région là il y a un
sentiment d'impunité on le voit là les
jeunes il y a aussi la présence sur les
réseaux sociaux ça c'est c'est quelque
chose de très très important donc quand
on parle un événement si on prend le
début d'un événement à la finalité où il
y a une décharge d'arme à feu mais il y
a une partie qui s'est peut-être passé
dans une cour d'école une autre partie
que c'est passé sur les réseaux sociaux
donc il faut travailler les services de
police il faut travailler à tous ces
niveaux là et on a besoin de nos
partenaires parce que les partenaires du
milieu scolaire du milieu communautaire
vous êtes impunité c'est que les jeunes
se disent
comme une inconscience par rapport une
banalisation une inconscience par
rapport à ce qu'ils peuvent leur arriver
une inconscience par rapport à la vie
humaine donc c'est un peu ça donc ça
c'est il y a une partie qui peut se
faire par nos services mais une partie
qui peut se faire par le milieu aussi
comment on les rejoint ces jeunes là
comment on les rejoint c'est sûr que la
police peut faire un bout de chemin
tantôt pierre parler de l'aspect
prévention dans les écoles et policiers
mais Dieu sait que le nerf la guerre est
dans les groupes communautaires dans les
travailleurs de rue ces gens-là je le
dis puis je le répète le confinement
c'est service de police est important on
doit recevoir des financement mais le
milieu communautaires 20 ans 30 ans 40
ans qui sont le terrain ils ont le tout
terrain bien mieux que nous
manque tellement surtout de la
pérennisation de leur financement c'est
ça le problème présentement qu'est-ce
qui se passe c'est du top down c'est
toujours de les institutions décide
quelque chose et demande au groupe
communauté de fitter dans l'enveloppe
budgétaire qui leur propose que ça soit
plus simple et c'est le contraire c'est
le milieu du terrain qui devrait dire
aux institutions ça c'est nos besoins
financer nous là-dessus c'est
intéressant c'est obligé d’accord c'est
le manque de gens qui se promènent dans
les parcs dans les écoles dans les lieux
où oui effectivement il faut te donner
d'autres options aux jeunes pierre le
dit faut te donner d'autres options aux
jeunes que une référence à un jeune qui
est criminalisé qui est déjà criminalisé
donc faut lui donner des solutions qui
sont gagnantes mais des solutions qui
sont propres à lui nous on peut pas
décider pour lui quelles sont ses
besoins parce qu'on quand il est arrivé
c'est de meurtres on a dit puis le
gouvernement du Québec a donné de
l'argent à la Ville de Montréal pour
qu'on engage davantage de policier et là
on a mis l'accent sur le fait qui
manquait de policiers vous vous dites
première chose que vous avez dit c'est
qu'il manque des travailleurs dans rue
plus que de policiers oui moi je dis
qu'il y en a besoin de policiers on en a
besoin mais si on a une vision à moyen
long terme la répression ponctuellement
à court terme est nécessaire obligatoire
faut vraiment calmer le jeu au niveau
des fusillades mais si on regarde un
moyen long terme qui qui dans la rue
avec les jeunes à l'école qui qu'une
bonne exemples que je sois que le
professeur avant que l'enfant ne
décroche si on ne finance pas le milieu
de la rue on va toujours être en
rattrapage en réaction en réaction
madame royes qui manque des policiers à
Montréal par ailleurs il y a des postes
de son pas comblés à Montréal donc c'est
ça l'investissement on remercie
d'ailleurs
l'implication du gouvernement de du
Québec pour nous fournir les policiers
dans les postes qui n'ont pas été
comblés est-ce que le citoyen va voir
plus de policiers ou ça va être à la
marge non assurément il va voir plus de
policiers mais il faut il faut doter ses
postes bien entendu
combien de plus de police
ce qui est prévu actuellement c'est
qu'on puisse ajouter un 450 policiers
qu'on vienne doter des postes vacants
autour de 450 policiers dans les cinq
prochaines années à la base ce qui
manque de policiers Nord je dirais qu'on
a eu du sport autant au niveau de la
ville une augmentation du budget on a ça
nous a permis d'acheter des enquêteurs
au niveau du ministère de la Sécurité
publique aussi évidemment le métier de
policier c'est un peu sans fin demain
matin on me donne 20 policiers on va
avoir plus de fan si on fait plus
d'opérations plus de restallations plus
d'intervention je vous dirais que
présentement la situation est bien
contrôlée puis je le répète j'ai pu mes
collègues en disant présentement les
services de police au Québec font le
maximum avec la capacité qu'ils ont la
répression de prévention de
renseignement là l'enjeu a moyen et long
terme ça va être la culture des armes à
feu le développement social
l'environnement donc c'est fascinant les
trois directrices de directeurs qui
disent dans le fond oui ça prend plus de
policiers oui pour le fonctionnement
mais ça beaucoup plus de travailleurs
sociaux de gens connaissent les jeunes
de gens qui travaillent et vous êtes
tous d'accord avec ça donc pas plus de
répression c'est vous il y a des gens de
8 9 10 ans qui sont déjà payés à 50-60
dollars par semaine pour faire le guide
pour les gang du rue c'est pas normal
c'est pas logique comment ça se fait que
ce jeune là écrit en bleu ou écrit en
rouge au primaire comment ça se fait que
ce jeune là que les antennes faut qu'on
le voit ça c'est pas normal le jeu le
professeur le coup je sens que le
travailleur de rue vont le voir avant le
détecter par leurs parents le prennent
en charge à trois autres amis à la fin
de l'école il va devoir aller au saquer
au lieu d'aller dans la rue il va devoir
suivre un programme sportif c'est ça la
prise en charge c'est ça la clé puis
vous dire sa campagne électorale je vous
le rappelle je vous ai pas politique là
en tant que vous dites au parti ça prend
plus de monde donc des budgets
simplifiés pour des groupes
communautaires vous êtes d'accord en
tout cas il faut les écouter
faut que ce soit pérenniser les budgets
souvent les groupes communautaires le
problème c'est qu'il doit travailler à
chaque année ou à chaque deux trois ans
pour aller chercher du budget il y a de
l'instabilité vous savez les deux
dernières années on a vu la
recrudescence de la violence en même
temps on a vécu le covid les groupes
communautaires on a vécu beaucoup de
télétravail ont été affaiblis puis fait
que l'encadrement puissiez aux jeunes
filet social a été affecté madame Roy
vous avez un défi
supplémentaire que vos deux collègues
dans la rétention de personnel sur les
20 embauches que vous deviez recevoir de
Nicolet il y en a 16 qui se sont
désistés pour venir à Montréal est-ce
que le fait de venir travailler à la
prise de Montréal c'est c'est plus aussi
attirant que ça ne l’était vous avez
peut-être raison sur ce point-là mais je
veux juste vous rappeler que les 16 on
les a comblés quand même ce qui arrive
c'est plus au niveau de notre processus
notre processus était un peu plus long
que certains certaines embauches dans
d'autres services de police qui
faisaient en sorte qu'on a perdu
certains
dernièrement cette semaine encore on a
eu une vingtaine de candidats qui sont
rentrés il y a ça tourne toujours autour
de 50% qui proviennent aussi d'autres
organisations mais est-ce que dans les
discours des gens responsables on doit
pas valoriser le travail des policiers
dans les dernières sorties que j'ai fait
j'ai beaucoup dit au niveau de la lutte
de la violence armée mais aussi pour nos
jeunes policiers ils ont besoin de la
part des citoyens mais ils ont besoin du
soutien des citoyens il faut valoriser
la fonction surtout maintenant avant
qu'ils ont se démobilisent énormément
c'est nécessaire de faire la promotion
ces cosmétiques et noble est extrêmement
complexe en 2022 est-ce que 60 menotté
on avait fait un reportage sur le
désengagement policier et patrouille
dans certains quartiers